[Music]
in Japanese mythology there's several
mentions of a dark Nether world a gloomy
mystical realm known as yomi no Kuni or
just yomi for short it's mainly
associated with the Japanese nature
religion Shintoism which proposes that
the World At Large is made up of three
primary layers with yomi existing at the
bottom while there's a variety of
interpretations about its true nature
the general consensus about yomi is that
of a Subterranean World drenched in
Perpetual Shadow a place where the
spirits of the deceased travel to after
passing it goes by a variety of names
and pseudonyms some of which include
Land of the Dead world of darkness and
land of Gloom in addition there's a few
locations which are speculated to be
either closely connected to yomi or one
and the same like nuni the land of roots
and Soo no Kuni or Hollow land because
of its characterization as a place deep
below the Earth some have drawn
parallels between yomi and the more
widely known hell or Hades however this
is not really an accurate comparison to
make yomi is not a place of fire and
brimstone torture and eternal damnation
there's no judgment no reward or
punishment and thus it can be viewed as
neither a paradise Nor Hell it's just a
place where Spirits go and hang out I
guess in that sense it has more in
common with the concept of limbo or
Purgatory than anything else unlike
Purgatory however which is often
visualized as a sort of separate reality
a dimension between Dimensions yomi is
allegedly a real tangible place that
shares a geographical continuation with
the mortal world I.E it exists on the
same plane as as Earth itself you can
even visit the area in Japan where
according to Legend the entrance to yomi
is set to exist though according to the
stories it was sealed off by a massive
Boulder as is to be expected the
Japanese underworld and various
characters associated with it have been
Incorporated in several works of fiction
All of which take creative Liberty and
put their own spin on it if you played
Persona 4 for example you're probably
familiar with the names isagi and
isanami which are two gods or Kami who
play a big role in the creation myth of
Japan and whose backstory is most
closely tied to yomi to oversimplify
isanami was the first Kami to die and
transition into the underworld meanwhile
isagi in an attempt to reunite with her
traveled to yomi only to be chased out
again by both isanami herself and an
ensemble of nightmare inducing
monstrosities which ultimately led to
isagi sealing the entrance to the
underworld again it's a gross
simplification of the actual story so if
you ever want to read the full thing
I'll put a link to it in the description
below just be advised that it gets
pretty weird at times anyway anyway
before we talk more about the Japanese
underworld let's first discuss its
significance for today's topic which as
you've probably guessed is the influence
it may have had on the Legend of Zelda
more specifically on the latest entry in
the series I suspect that tears of the
Kingdom's depths have been inspired by
the concept of yomi as the two share
quite a few similarities from the dark
and gloomy atmosphere the presence of
lingering spirits to its vast
Subterranean landscape unlike the many
exotic Dimensions seen across the series
like the Dark World Twilight realm and
parallel Dimensions like termina the
depths are different in that they don't
require some sort of magic portal to
access instead you just drop down into a
crevice and transition into the world
below Hyrule seamlessly this implies
that the depths are not in fact a
separate Dimension but simply a massive
hollow space that has existed deep below
the kingdom for who knows how long maybe
since the world's creation it's a common
theme in Zelda where the deeper you go
the more you'll be confronted by all
sorts of Supernatural elements from
desolate Crypts to nightmare's
hellscapes and the influences Behind
These locations can vary for example the
basement level of Skyward sword's
ancient sistern is most likely based on
the concept of joku the Buddhist
equivalent of Hell which I'm not going
to show too much of because i' prefer if
this video stays monetized like
seriously a lot of the artwork is pretty
messed up as opposed to yomi jigoku is a
place of torture and Punishment albeit
not for eternity and since the ancient
sister as a whole is themed after
Buddhism it's all but certain that joku
was the main inspiration for the bottom
half of this dungeon it even features a
gameplay section based on a famous
Buddhist Legend where a sinner tries to
escape from Hell by climbing up a
spider's thread however that's not what
we see in tears of the Kingdom's
Underworld the depths are mostly just
dark and melancholic it has its own
ecosystem with all sorts of unique
vegetation and fauna there's remnants of
Mines factories and other activity from
living people if it wasn't for the
supernatural elements The Depths could
easily be mistaken for just an oversized
cave system and nothing more However the
fact that it does feature things like
Spirits monsters and demonic statues who
are in the business of trading Souls
hints that the depths are definitely
more than that and has some sort of
connection to the
[Laughter]
afterlife the most compelling evidence
for this by far are the bargainers it
seems the main purpose of these Godlike
entities trapped in stone is to serve as
a sort of guide for the souls who find
themselves trapped down here to help
them transition into the Afterlife and
when they do they do so without passing
judgment in their own words good and
evil are futile Concepts to them to me
this is the most telling feature of the
depths that ties it to the Shinto
underworld as opposed to say the
Christian or Buddhist hell because it
doesn't seem to matter who these Spirits
were or what they did in life they're
all treated equally while doing research
for this video it became apparent that
trying to paint an accurate picture of
yomi is surprisingly difficult because
despite its increased popularity as a
topic or as a source of inspiration for
things like horror stories yomi isn't
actually all that prevalent in the shint
religion especially in the current day
Shintoism tends to focus more on life
here and now as opposed to whatever
comes after so simple things like what
the underworld looks like exactly where
it's located or what ultimately happens
to Spirits once they enter it are left
pretty vague hence why depictions of
this elusive world can vary so greatly
between media it's all based on
interpretations of ancient texts and
folklore few of which go into great
detail about yomi itself and instead
focuses more on the characters and the
events that take place there the
earliest mention of yomi No Kuni in
Japanese mythology is in the kojiki
which is basically a collection of old
myths and legends divided into three
books or volumes they are considered to
be the oldest surviving writings from
ancient Japan and yomi is only featured
twice once in the aformentioned creation
story involving Izanagi and isanami and
again in a later story about the God of
storms susano who ends up getting
banished to yomi for reasons I won't get
into here again links to these stories
will be in the description below prior
to the the kojiki the concept of yomi
was most likely derived from the Chinese
underworld called hang Chen because not
only do they share a lot of traits but
also the kanji are identical in fact
while making the thumbnail for this
video my fiance who is from China walked
into my office and said you know that's
a very scary word for us to which I said
deal with it actually I I didn't say
that but I did ask her for a definition
and according to her it roughly
translates to underground spring
underworld or Land of the Dead same as
in Japanese how two characters can
translate to so many different things
will forever be a mystery to me but I
mean Asian languages are about as alien
to me as Mark Zuckerberg is so while
it's not easy to pinpoint the exact
nature of yomi and its inner workings we
can at least go over some of the alleged
features which I think are somewhat
proportional to tears of the kingdoms on
the world the most common
characteristics that are repeated
throughout multiple sources are dark
shadowy gloomy foggy and cold I also
found a couple of sources that claim
that some parts of yomi can mirror
locations from the world above it can
look similar yet
different this is a common theme in the
depths as well the entire map is
essentially an inverse of holl's
landscape mountains above are valleys
below and vice versa most landmarks have
an accompanying structure below it and
the names of the light roots are the
names of the shrines in Reverse
furthermore according to a Shinto
scholar and theologist yomi is not just
a dark and Barren Wasteland quote it
should not mistakenly Be Imagined that
this realm is devoid of light it has
food clothing and houses of various
kinds similar to those of the visible
World proof of this may be found in
accounts in which a person has
occasionally returned to tell of the
realm of the dead end quote that last
sentence indicates that yomi is not
exclusive to dead people alone and has
in fact been visited by the living as
well some of which return to tell the
tale I do have to clarify that just
because yomi is neither hell nor
Paradise it's definitely not without
danger those who decide decide to
venture here for one reason or another
do run a considerable risk of getting
trapped here forever joining the dead
and the same applies to the depts as
well whoever sets foot down here can
easily fall victim to the many dangers
lurking in the dark and become the next
soul to be added to the collection
there's even an account from the yiga
that says that some of the clansmen had
their souls taken from them when they
tried to approach the bargainer statues
as for the spirits who reside in yomi
their experience is described as a
gloomy and shadowy existence and that
the only suffering they endure if any at
all is their separation from their
living loved ones the last thing to
highlight is that aside from Spirits and
the occasional living visitor yomi is
also home to an ensemble of Kami like
the aformentioned ruler of the
Underworld isanami the god of storm
susano and others like the Thunder God D
Jin who was born in the Underworld with
all that said I think it's time we leave
the mythology portion behind for the
most part and focus on some of the in
Universe aspects of Tears of the
Kingdom's Nether world and theorize
about some of the stuff going on down
here to start off I think this place is
definitely part of a Natural Balance a
balance pertaining to the cycle of life
and death in particular it seems that
most individuals who die in Hyrule will
eventually transition into the
underworld and the only exceptions seem
to be special individuals who continue
to have some sort of obligation to the
mortal world those who have some sort of
higher purpose or unfinished business
however it's also implied that the
depths are not the final destination for
these spirits but rather an intermediate
one because as mentioned before the bar
statues will eventually guide these lost
souls into the actual afterlife whatever
or wherever that may be but what's
unclear is how this transition is
supposed to work under normal
circumstances in game link has to
physically collect these spirits and
then offer them up to the Statue which
suggest that the bargainer statues
require assistance from one or more
appointed individuals who carry out this
task and who knows maybe the tunic of
the depths is somehow connected to these
people or maybe the statues of this
mysterious unknown race are one idea
I've been toying around with is that
these beings could have been native to
the underworld and perhaps collaborated
with the bargainers at one point one of
the features on these statues is that
they're holding a spherical object in
their left hand which I think most
people assume is some sort of rock or
mineral however while inspecting the
model I noticed that The Rock has a
swirl like pattern on it which is
normally quite difficult to see because
of the low light conditions so maybe
instead of a rock it's supposed to be a
stylistic depiction of something else
perhaps a postp now I do have to clarify
that the reason why this pattern is
visible is because this object is
actually borrowing a piece of the same
texture used for the pedestal the statue
stands on so who knows maybe it is just
a rock but I do think it's worth
pointing out at least it's also possible
that under normal circumstances Spirits
do have the ability to find their way to
the bargainers on their own merits but
that ganondorf's presence and influence
on the underworld is somehow disturbing
this process whatever the case may be
it's clear that there are multiple
outside forces at work in the Underworld
on the one hand we have the zonai in
collaboration with other species who not
only mined for resources down here but
also constructed the light routs to
dispel some of the darkness making the
area more habitable for those who dwell
in the light and on the other side of
the coin we have Ganondorf whose Gloom
has been spreading across the underworld
like a disease this infestation mainly
takes on the form of roots snaking
through the underworld and spreading is
corruption though spreading might not be
the right term to use instead sapping or
draining seems to be more accurate you
can clearly see a substance pulsating
through these roots which accumulates at
gloom's Lair a massive tree likee
structure deep below the hro castle area
and at the heart of this tree of Horrors
is Ganondorf drawing this substance in
and using it to revitalize himself or
rehydrate if you will it seems the demon
king is quite literally sucking the
underworld dry my own interpretation is
that the depths are not inherently a
place of evil on the contrary I think
the surface and the underworld serve as
a kind of equilibrium A system that
recycles energy or life force which has
been hijacked by Ganondorf things that
die on the surface go to the underworld
and in turn the energy that made up
these life forms is stripped to its most
basic form only to rise back up through
the Earth to be reused for New Life of
course I can't really prove that this is
how it works but it's the most
compelling idea I can come up with one
that reveals a certain Beauty to this
otherwise dark and Eerie place it's
apparent that the depths are incredibly
ancient we can find all sorts of things
that are indicative of a long history
like these massive fossilized tree roots
Roots which are found underneath areas
on the surface that have little to no
vegetation like below the grudo
highlands for example maybe in an age
long ago these mountains were part of a
lush forest and looked more like the
mountains in faren you may have noticed
that in general Roots seem to be a bit
of a recurring theme in tears of the
Kingdom we have gloom's Lair the light
Roots the giant fossilized Roots the
Roots of the decer tree which extend all
the way down to the underworld as well
there's clearly a lot of energy
emanating from this place and heck it
may even be the true source of of
ancient energy it is kind of in the name
already the residual energy from an
ancient world the roots of hyru
Providence it might even be a metaphor
for the roots of the Zelda series as a
whole which is something the developers
have been calling back to since breath
the wild The Last Detail I want to point
out is that despite its enormous size
there's a good chance that we haven't
even seen the full extent of the
underworld there's of course the
possibility that it stretches beyond the
border of hyu itself and that other
lands and kingdoms have their own
equivalent but even more unsettling is
the option that the deps go much much
deeper than we're allowed to see in this
game the highest point you can reach in
tear of the Kingdom's Overworld without
glitches or cheats of course is 3,300
units on the z-axis and the absolute
lowest you can physically go is minus
2525 which is located at glooms Lair and
just to clarify the zero Mark for the
z-axis is sea level that's a total of
5,825 units of vertical space to explore
which is pretty insane considering that
Hyrule is about 8,000 units north to
south however as you've probably noticed
the deepest point isn't on Solid Ground
instead it's the boundary of a
bottomless hole the absolute maximum
amount of depth you can reach before
link voids out as it's called so what's
at the bottom of this hole bre the wild
has already proven that just because a
Chasm is inaccessible in one game
doesn't mean it's bottomless it's just
the developer setting boundaries for the
explorable space but from an in Universe
perspective this hole has to lead
somewhere and where to or how deep it
actually goes is something we can only
imagine maybe it leads to actual hell
what's most striking to me about this
general area is that there's already
pre-existing zonai architecture here
which I'd imagine was built before
Ganondorf was trapped in the Underworld
I mean there's literally a diving
platform right at the edge of this
bottomless abyss and God Only Knows Why
or what it was used for I don't know
maybe the zonai didn't disappear back
into the heavens and instead they all
cannonballed into the Earth's
core and I think that pretty much covers
it for today obviously there's a lot
more to the depths in general and I'm
sure creators including myself will
continue to find ideas to explore and
theorize about I also want to emphasize
that just because the depts share a few
similarities to the Japanese underworld
of yomi that of course doesn't mean that
I'm proposing that they are the same in
the literal sense the comparisons I've
given today are obviously cherry-picked
to tell a compelling story I do
genuinely think the concept of yomi had
some degree of influence on the way the
depths are portrayed but I would be
remiss if I didn't mention that there
are definitely things that aren't found
in one or the other and you know this is
to be expected Zelda has never borrowed
from just one single Source it's a
hodgepodge of various cultural
influences from Christianity to Middle
Eastern culture Buddhism Shintoism alien
folklore all mixed in with the
developers own imagination so it's
rarely as simple as saying yeah this
place is totally from that one religion
or from that specific movie more likely
It's a combination of several things
that said I do think it's beneficial to
study these influences big or small as
they may be because it offers a window
into the minds of the developers and can
help to unravel what it is that they may
have tried to convey the ancient sistern
is a prime example of that if you don't
know anything about Buddhism it's just a
dungeon like any other but once you know
why it looks and functions the way it
does it elevates the experience to a
whole new level thank you for watching
what was supposed to be my Halloween
episode but that ship has sailed
unfortunately so sorry for that I guess
we can still pretend like it's Halloween
anyway a special thanks to my newest
supporter Nick deer and of course to the
rest of my lovely patreons and channel
members you continue to make this
channel possible have an amazing week
and I hope to see you all next
[Music]
time
d